hey a record-setting nine awards tonight
what does that mean to you you you have
you've changed the game yes
holy cow what does it mean
i mean to me it means that the work that
everybody has put in over six years
has you know paid off royally
um a lot of hard work i think this also
means
that there's a conversation to be had
amongst networks and streamers
across uh entertainment that shows need
to be given
time to grow and they need to be given
space and they need to be given seasons
to develop because we are the prime
example of a show that would likely have
been cancelled on a network in america
and yet here we are so i do hope that
conversations are being had
uh among network people about
giving shows a shot because let this be
an example
of of what can happen when you do i was
going to mention that because really
coming to netflix and the pandemic
hitting really helped you out
weirdly enough well that's true a lot of
people
were at home binge watching
shows and as catherine pointed out
before
the idea that you're watching a family
that is
living in two adjoining rooms in a motel
you know and everybody else binge
watching is
isolating in their own home and
quarantining
um i think there was definitely a
familiarity there and something that
they could uh
latch onto and uh empathize with
okay does this mean that there will be
some kind of return or maybe a movie
or something you can't go out with nine
awards and become the first show to
sweep
all four acting categories the directing
writing
and series award and just go poof into
the night i've been sending
dan one dollar bills in the mail every
single day
as a bribe to make him write a movie but
so far
nothing i actually think that this sort
of solidifies that we went out on a good
note um and it would take a really
freaking good idea
to top whatever just happened check your
inbox though because a couple people
here may have sent a few ideas
okay tbd we'll continue the conversation
i guess tomorrow
months more conversations are added but
i would absolutely love to continue
telling these stories it's been the
greatest
pleasure and the greatest gift the final
season on netflix in october right
from what i believe i believe it's
october uh yes i believe you're right
october or maybe tomorrow if they have
the documentary
that goes with the last or maybe
tomorrow
we'll see that i don't know yeah anyway
okay how's the party going to be in
toronto tonight how are you guys going
to turn up
very safely drinking through masks
obviously
we've got socially distanced fun over
here in canada
socially distance fun we've got the back
bacon and the frying pans
ready to go we've got the beer and the
coolers
[Laughter]
uh we're all set and where's the guy in
the hazmat suit who gave out all those
awards did he just come to canada with
did he
he came with a lot of awards up there it
was a she's a lady
it was a lady and she's still here
and the funny thing about the hazmat
suits um they were even worse than what
happens to my glasses
when i breathe the poor hazmat suit just
completely fogged up and i watched her
panic
before each award going out just trying
to like clear the hazmat suit
so that she could see her way to the
podium
so next time we need a little bit of
ventilation i think
in those suits i also want to tell you
that john oliver was concerned that
even though he won that you might
somehow sneak in and steal his category
too
as do i as do we all very very much we
would never
we would never listen you all
congratulations cheers to you have a
hell of a night
cannot wait for the final season on
netflix but also
can't wait for the movie right movie